As we go to our next game,
Conspiracy on the Conspira-Seas.
It's spring break time,
which means thousands
of depraved college students
will be filing onto cruise ships
across the seven seas.
But this year they may have to
share the decks
with another group of people
who should be separated
from society:
conspiracy theorists!
Uh, this is absolutely true.
It's a conspiracy-themed cruise.
I would literally rather be on
a boat raided by Somali pirates
than floating around
on this barge
full of gray ponytails.
According to Jezebel,
the Conspira-Sea Cruise
took its maiden voyage
in January. Or did it?!
I'm kidding. Uh, with
the stated goal of uncovering
the "mind-blowing truth"
about Monsanto,
bee colony collapse, autism,
and, of course,
why the cruise has a mysterious
30:1 male-to-female ratio,
all while drinking
double margaritas
during '80s Karaoke Night
on Deck B.
With Isaac. Comedians,
what are some things
you might overhear
on a conspiracy theory cruise?
In 60 seconds and begin.
-Drew.
-Chocolate Tower 7 is down.
-I think it was an inside job.
-All right, points.
-Andy.
-Me? No, I love vaccines.
In fact, this piña colada
is full of them.
All right, points. Andy.
Maybe I did take a (bleep)
in the pool.
Or maybe we all took a (bleep)
-Whoa...
-Points.
Well, I guess...
I guess that would explain
all the (bleep) in the pool.
-Drew. -I wish my tummy was
as flat as the Earth.
Points. Kulap.
I'm beginning to think
that all of the bodies of water
-are somehow connected.
-All right, points.
-Andy.
-I heard that Han Solo
and Indiana Jones
are the same guy.
-Whoa...
-Points.
-Drew. -Uh, meet you
at the Grassy Knoll Bar.
-We're taking shots.
-All right. Points. -Oh! Drew!